to welcome everyone to our
weekly biomedical informatics research
conference
on this gorgeous day and we're all um
behind our screens and inside our homes
or maybe some people are outside
um but anyways it gives me great
pleasure to wreck
to um introduce um an
outside speaker someone from outside
ohsu and
maybe one silver lining of the pandemic
is that we've been able to have a few
more
uh people than we might ordinarily have
and they don't have to
travel even though most people would
probably prefer to be in portland on
our sunny 80 degree day today but
anyways um
i'm happy to introduce dr sarah
sarah collins-rossetti who is an
assistant professor
of biomedical informatics and nursing at
columbia
university um you can see that she has
both an rn and phd
her research is focused on identifying
and intervening on patient risk for harm
by applying computational tools
to mine and extract value from ehr data
she also is an experienced critical care
nurse
and received her phd in nursing from
columbia and then did a postdoctoral
fellowship in informatics also at
columbia
she has become involved in this
interesting project
that we've invited her to talk about
today
and um this um i'm sure that most of you
know this is a real critical critical
issue that we face now
in the field and in health care of
documentation burden
so she's going to talk to us about an
initiative that a number of institutions
including
amia and nlm are involved with to reduce
documentation burden i also would like
to
point out that sarah was selected as a
2019 recipient of the presidential early
career award for scientists and
engineers
or p case which is the highest honor
bestowed by the u.s government to
outstanding scientists and engineers
who are beginning their independent
research careers and show exceptional
promise for
leadership in science and technology so
at this point
i will turn it over to sarah she will
present her
talk as usual you can type into the chat
box although she probably won't see it
until the end of the talk
and then when she's done um we'll
she can answer questions from the chat
or people can feel free to unmute and
ask the question verbally
so go ahead sarah great
um thank you so much bill it would be
wonderful to be there in person
but um this is just as good for this
year
so um yes today i'm going to speak about
this project on documentation decreasing
documentation burden i'm going to talk
about
the nlm funded symposium that we have
this winter
and then also at the end i'll talk about
some of my specific research
um that that really relates to this
problem
too um great
and so documentation burden has been
recognized increasingly
recognized uh throughout our country um
it's it's not
solely a problem in our country
we've learned through the symposium we
held there are issues certainly
internationally as well
but um there is a major focused
focus on it nationally and that really
does
also relate to things such as our
reimbursement models
you know that that are particular to
to the us um and so the national academy
of medicine
has recognized the problem of
documentation burden
specifically as it links to clinician
burnout
and there are studies that have
associated the two
um the 21st century cures act also
does recognize burden in the way that
um that congress actually required
uh the department of health and human
services to act
on on this problem and so kind of
um in that realm onc has taken the lead
in work to reduce documentation burden
they
published their final report um recently
on
strategy on reducing regulatory and
administrative burden
relating to the use of health i.t and
ehrs
um and there's also the quadruple aim so
for many years we have the triple aim
and
um you know which had to do with
enhancing the patient experience
improving population health and reducing
costs
and the quadruple aim then includes
improving the work life of the health
care provider and so this is just seen
from mult from many perspectives um you
know as increasingly important
some background on documentation burden
i actually didn't want to spend
that much time during this talk talking
about you know essentially
the literature review of it um
through the symposium that i'll talk
about we have
a website up which actually has a really
nice set of resources we've put together
of you know publications
that um that discuss
documentation burden you know
peer-reviewed publications and some
others
too so you see those links here and i'm
happy to share these slides
um with you after as well but
you know just kind of sum it up a little
bit
um we know that ehrs are essentially in
their infancy you know when we really
think about where we were with
meaningful use
and where we are now if we look at that
timeline
for example um versus how long we were
using paper records
you know it hasn't actually been that
long so when you reflect on it from that
perspective
you know you can start to see there's
much
opportunity and i'm sure many of you
know to increase the usability of our
records but other things too
you know there were workflow processes
that were essentially just taken from
the paper world and put into each other
so we still kind of struggle with those
and then of course there's the regular
regulatory area
and reimbursement area and i'll talk
kind of about those domains that we
identified um during our symposium
or that i should say the framework we've
used
which identified those domains during
our symposium
uh one one piece of work to highlight
um comes from a phd student in mala
in my lab um amanda moy who did a
systematic review
of approaches to measure clinician
documentation burden among physicians
and nurses
and essentially you know i just want to
highlight this because i think it's
important as we
talk as i'm talking about what we
learned during
this mlm funded symposium that we put on
you know we have to always remember if
we want to
actually make a change and a difference
we need to measure that difference right
and so
we need to be measuring that now if we
want the change
to if we want to understand if we made a
change in a year five years or ten years
um but really there's a there's a lack
of standard and validated measures of
clinician documentation
burden there are some core concepts that
seem to be consistently measured so
effort that clinicians put in
and that can be looked at through a few
different ways usage
and workload in the ehr you know
logging into the hr after hours and
remotely
the number of administrative versus
clinical tasks
you can look at cognitive workload
um you can look at fragmentation of the
workflow
and then the level in which you know
pain patient interaction is kind of
um impacted um but again you know
it there aren't consistent measures for
each of those
um and then time is the other major
category so looking at the average time
spent in the record
the proportion of time spent on
different activities
the timeliness of completion of the
record etc
and then we found 11 different units of
analysis for time for example
um you know so so there's some work to
be done in how we measure it so that we
can be more consistent
and actually determine if we've improved
um so this slide here highlights the
symposium which i've been referring to
which was titled 25x5 symposium to
reduce
documentation burden on u.s clinicians
by 75
by 2025. so we want to be at a level of
25
of what we're at now in the next five
years
and again we need to be able to measure
in order in order to
determine if we get there so i just want
to recognize my co-chair trent rosenblum
from vanderbilt
and steering committee members that you
see here
there's the link to our website as well
so please feel free to access that
all of the talks that were given during
the symposium which ran for six weeks um
in january and
this past january and february are up
there both the video as well as the
powerpoint
so it really is a nice resource and i
encourage you to
to look at it the work from the
symposium is ongoing
um and and i'll kind of talk about where
we are
with that but i want to make that clear
up front um so our goals were to create
a meeting that engages a diverse group
of
key stakeholders and leaders focused on
reducing documentation
burden to assess the likely potential
for burden reduction within each
category of documentation burden tasks
to establish approaches for immediate
short-term
and longer-term elimination of clinical
documentation burden
and to develop a what we call 25x5
community of stakeholders and allies to
keep momentum going
to support dissemination and change we
also
want to maximize tequity of any proposed
solutions and this was very important
to us um and and was looked at
through we established a um
a diversity equity and inclusion
committee to look at this so tequila
is defined as the consideration design
development and implementation
of technology solutions that promote
assure and potentially enhance
health equity
our principles of engagement
these were kind of laying the groundwork
as we
started the symposium and bringing
together
a diverse group of stakeholders so we
wanted to make sure
that solutions that were proposed for
example leveraged technology and
and existing data inputs were
appropriate in order to do things such
as reduce re-documentation of items
already captured during other intake
processes
but there should be no erosion of care
standards
you know should maintain high quality
safety value efficiency access
to care throughout any
any proposed solutions for example to
maximize clarity of proposed rules
to minimize misinterpretation by health
systems and providers
and we found that there certainly are
can be a lot of
confusion sometimes especially in the
regulatory domain
and there should be no wholesale
shifting of work from one clinician to
another clinician
that we actually are seeking to
eliminate unnecessary documentation
altogether
rather than moving it from one um
type of health care provider to another
type of healthcare provider
so just so you have a sense of what we
actually
did i said there were six sessions
they were held on friday afternoons for
two hours each and
in the first one we had you know
introductions but we were focused on
talking about current challenges related
to what
we document in the second session
current challenges related to
how we document the third session we
had some exemplars presenting and
talking about their key successes and
what we could learn from them
the fourth session was talking about
emerging and future innovations as
solutions
and that included um that included a
panel
from the vendor industry community
um the fifth session was our first
kind of reactor and prioritization
session so we started our breakout
sessions during
during this week and then we continued
breakout sessions in session six as well
as had
a nice plenary um presentation from
christine sinsky
we had over 300 participants
joining you know across the weeks which
was
really just wonderful uh to see and i
think
certainly the virtual format actually
ended up being
really great to allow more participation
than certainly
would have occurred in person
so um just quickly to highlight some of
the specific
speakers this is from um
our first week so a panel on policy and
reimbursement issues and a panel on
clinical practice and documentation
issues
um we also had um other panels focus on
for instance current challenges around
how this was around how we document such
as workflow and usability issues
and you know like i said all the
resources are online so i don't want to
just
rehash you know what they all said
because we have
more content to talk about actually in
terms of the outputs of the symposium
but to highlight some key points here um
and you'll see this slide is borrowed um
from kevin johnson where actually
we are presenting a panel next week at
the amia clinical informatics conference
and so this
this slide is from that deck um
but you know there was some um
presentations
um andy gettinger from onc talked about
21st century tours and some of the
changes there
mary greene from cms
talked about prior authorization how it
should be simplified and eliminated
and that work is underway looking at
documentation requirements
and um the importance of getting
providers clear guidance about
requirements
there was also um talks talking about
you know the need to measure change and
learn
from that um with transparency
you know for frontline um you know
providers and builders presumably
um and then then you know it was noted
the importance of
any work that we do really looking at
it from the perspective of the
environmental and social impact
as well um and kind of this process
re-engineering
you know it was mentioned quite a few
times throughout the symposium
in the past year lots of changes have
been made at various sites
to the documentation um you know
electronic health record configurations
that exist for example can we learn from
that
you know what what was done to
streamline things
um just a few more points to highlight
here
the need to address usability challenges
of duplicate documentation
issues around siloed notes and
readability of the output
better use of data generated through
internet of things you know just
emerging technologies
patient reported outcomes and health
information exchange
that um it's a that workflow
integration is incredibly important and
attention to
you know who what when where why and how
they are documenting
there's a lot of talk about clicks and
balancing that with the need for
structured data
and that there are some frameworks that
can be used to help address
you know the volume of clicks that we
that we require
um and i'll talk a little bit about some
um exemplars that had success in that
area
um and then there was a pretty strong
focus throughout on this notion of
teams you know but really expanding kind
of our notion of teams
you know to to make them even bigger and
better
if you will but really having our
documentation
reflect that so well we may have care
teams we don't have shared
team documentation for the most part you
know across most
areas um and looking at more complex
models
that really could benefit team-based
care but then
benefit the documentation in order to
reduce
redundancy across members of the care
team having to document the same thing
over and over again um new capabilities
through speech recognition was a focus
area as well
and then of course copy and paste came
up um you know
noting that that's a way that there can
be some consistency in the documentation
but it can certainly propagate
misinformation it increases note load
um you know in a variety of of usability
and
in workarounds um related to that too so
it's
it's not necessarily um a good thing
we also had an amazing
um chat so we held the symposium on zoom
and you know the chat log was just
phenomenal and the attendees
you know they were um experts
in our field and related fields you know
just within healthcare
in general um so it was really
an incredible group of people that were
very actively um writing in the chat
and so i i call it out specifically not
because i have
particular content from the chat to
share with you but because we've
actually posted them we de-identified
them and we've posted them
on our website so they're available
our team is starting to look at um
how we can use some text mining
of it to analyze the chat because we you
know it's really valuable and we want to
do that
we haven't um we have you know we're
just starting it on that
but i think it'll be exciting to see
what emerges from it
uh to highlight you know our focus on
diversity equity inclusion and what that
really means when you talk about
documentation burden
and so kendra keto led um led this talk
and
and this committee um but it's to
recognize
you know where our documentation comes
from and so as we talk about
needing to change the documentation we
need to reflect
kind of on where it comes from and the
issues
some of the issues driving it and some
of the issues of what's missing
from it um because it's not
it's it we need to think about it too
when we talk about reducing
documentation burden might not
always just be taking things out of the
record
but that um you know culture
organization
organizations people technology all
impact the structure of the
documentation
that we have when we think about the
process of documentation
you know we have to raise the question
of people who's defining the goals of
documentation and i see some of these
questions really
starting to um to kind of broaden
perhaps with our with the new
information blocking rules coming out
and you know patients having
more um easy access to their chart too
that we might look at these um questions
more and differently
and then outcomes that information is
filtered through systems and processes
and so what we're recording
is just a snapshot of really the care
that occurs
and and to just make sure to look at
documentation through these lenses to
make sure that we can
um that that we're always considering
you know how our documentation
structures
our processes impact health equity
to highlight the exemplars um these
were some of our exemplars um so one
from hong kong
one from the uk one from
the da vinci project from hl7
and then another um from
hda healthcare system um
and then another from university of
colorado
also from vanderbilt um and then
from penn which was actually um
a company founded
called caroline and then um
also from the cancer resource center of
the desert
which um talked talked about
including diversity equity and inclusion
um approaches
so i don't have time to highlight all
the exemplars and i you know i don't
think that would be the most valuable
use of the time they are online but just
just to
reiterate some main points this is just
a slide from one exemplar
and i like this slide because it shows
just how much extra
documentation is there in our records
that is that you can get rid of
um and i think it's important to reflect
on that so 496 flowsheet roads
eliminated from
uc health ehr when they really started
in on this work
they then had 18 fear of minutes and
flow sheets
um for nurses and in this work was
focused on nursing
so that equated to 64 000 rn
hours worth over 2.8 million annually
um and they equated that to 360 million
fewer clicks a year
so obviously you know context matters
you know what's your denominator here
and all of that but the numbers are big
and it just points to the fact that
there's a lot that can be done and so if
this is what one site could do
um you know and and they're using
um they were using epic you know a
vendor that many many sites use
you know that there's room there's room
for improvement at
at perhaps a lot of other sites with the
overbuild that we know occurs
so some takeaways from the exemplars
exemplars are doing excellent work
um you know there are great tangible
results
unfortunately it seems that there's a
lack of broad learning
from what they're doing at these you
know individual sites
lack of dissemination of it and spread
to other providers and health systems
you know that's really not happening you
don't really see as much
of that written up in the peer-reviewed
literature for example
um and so you know we think that there's
a lot of opportunity
to expand that dissemination whether it
is through peer-reviewed literature or
otherwise
um you know just that dissemination to
happen and that spread
um to happen and we think that
partnering certainly with vendors and
policy advocacy groups
should happen as well the international
groups that presented
while they don't have the same
reimbursement regulatory constraints
they still experience burden
and are focused on decreasing the size
of their hr content notes so that speaks
to
the fact that all of our you know
documentation burden probably isn't
driven by just reimbursement and
regulatory
demands as well and we pretty much know
that but i think that that kind of helps
drive the point home as well
so one thing that we also did before the
symposium started and then we shared
these results at the symposium
you know everyone knows this was quite a
unique year
um with the coved 19 pandemic
our hospitals were extremely burdened
with you know limited resources
and the acuity of patients and sheer
number of patients particularly in the
icus
and we know that nurses physicians and
other clinicians
and other staff at the hospital we're
really over
um you know over overworked um
at various points so a lot of sites
um as well as um some
laws and state laws and otherwise you
know said okay we're going to decrease
the regulations on
your documentation and for the most part
those may have been decreased
except in the area of medications
um but so so we surveyed we
did a national survey like what changes
did you make
locally um to your system now the survey
was sent out
um uh kind of in
a snowball sampling approach right so we
use professional listservs
we asked um clinicians and
informaticians
and so forth to forward it to their
respective groups
so we couldn't calculate a sample size
because of that but but
but we wanted to increase you know the
breadth
of responses that we got so that seemed
appropriate
but we got 351 responses so our findings
were that
the majority of sites experienced in
telehealth expansion i think
i think this is already pretty well
known um and they were preferred in the
context of documentation
burden they preferred that that remained
permanent
over two-thirds experienced telehealth
coding changes for e
m um the majority of the sites
supported additional documentation
strategies associated with
hr usability and this included
eliminating alerts for example
are optimizing the login process
um as well as data entry so things such
as
documenting only pertinent positives as
opposed to
you know the entire um
um you know system review
um and that there's less support though
for shifting work to ancillary staff
and so more support for changing the
actual hr configuration
than the shifting of documentation
but there were also variability in
perceptions and experience of
documentation burden
so some people preferred the charting by
exception that might have been
implemented and others did not in the
context of documentation burden so there
were pros and cons
um you know throughout
so then switching gears a little to our
output and findings from the symposium
so i had said how during our final two
weeks
we had breakout sessions and we used the
ania
framark the american nursing informatics
association
that is put forward this
um framework uh focused on documentation
burden and they outlined six
domains of burden so reimbursement
regulatory
quality usability interoperability and
this
this last one called self-imposed so
essentially
especially for you know clinicians or
those that work with ehr
systems out there you know we've done it
to ourselves right we over built that
system even though the regulations or
reimbursement
um you know didn't require it
for example um and and so that was our
sixth
uh domain so we had we held breakout
sessions
um that fell uh within each of these
domains and so we had over 100
participants
in the breakout sessions we had 19
breakout groups there were just
you know some breakout groups that
repeated across domains
so that we could have a zoom appropriate
number
per per group so we had a lot of data
that generated from this
so now talking about our methods to
actually analyze that data
um post the symposium so we identified
82 action items so i i should say two
that the breakout groups were charged
with identifying
action items in their domain that
would help to reduce documentation
burden
and so from the content generated there
were 82 action items and these mapped
to four different themes which we
identified accountability evidence
matters
education and training and innovation of
technology
and then we also mapped these you know
kind of orthogonally
to three stakeholder groups provider and
health system
um so the stakeholder groups were
intended to be specific
calls to action so provider and health
system calls to action
vendor calls to action and policy
advocacy calls to action
so um just a little breakdown here of
the themes
around accountability there is the
notion
not to work in silos that we need
clarity of roles
and cohesive understanding of
requirements among agencies and
stakeholders
that evidence matters that we need
evidence-based practice in forming
measures
this came across very strongly across
several different
breakout groups across the domains that
we have for instance you know regular
regulations
um from accrediting agencies that
there's not clear evidence behind those
regulations and it can be quite
frustrating
um at the health system level
um in terms of trying to comply with
them while trying to maintain
you know a record that um that supports
quality
of quality care um and so the need to
generate evidence
around that um and also get clinician
input
that there's a need for education and
training so documentation requirements
and standards
are needed there's a need for brevity
and clarity training for new clinicians
so how to be concise
and how to appropriately be concise in
your notes for example
as opposed to copy and paste
and to focus on quality of the content
in your notes over quantity
um also to incentivize training um
were some key points there and then
innovation of technology
so we need to start applying new
technology
that is available you know voice
recognition and other other
um types of aai and platforms um
as well as increasing interoperability
because that's also seen
as a path to reducing um
re-documentation
of information in our records you know
just leading to
information overload which is also a
form of burden
so then those calls to action that i
talked about that we map to those three
stakeholder groups so for providers and
health systems
it was noted that within the themes of
accountability and evidence they should
establish guiding principles for adding
documentation
to the ehr with multi-disciplinary
collaboration led by clinician
experts so it really should be
clinician-led
and generate evidence for reduced
documentation and impact on risk
compliance and removing documentation
that isn't positively impactful in terms
of education and training
they should develop and host a national
road show
you know on the education that can occur
directed towards
professional clinicians and clinicians
in training
and that particularly for med students
and residents
universities and health centers should
train on brevity
in addition to completeness around
technical innovations to expect
or support real-time information
retrieval this came through a few times
um strongly in the breakout groups that
if you can in more
real time get that information within
the ehr that it's easier to access
then you're less likely to redundantly
document it
um and then to implement
interdisciplinary notes and team-based
documentation and that
that was a theme right from the start of
the symposium
that vendors should around
accountability and evidence
promote an ecosystem of interoperable
systems
to allow for complementary technology
beyond a single
hr vendor develop metrics to review
and a user's documentation based on life
efficiency redundancy
and provide ongoing user feedback and
peer benchmarking
related to education and training to
package the best training practices into
toolkits
to promote users workflow revisioning
and best practices
to plan recognition programs and
publicize exemplars to incentivize the
sharing of documentation burden
reduction success stories and around
technical innovation to create
simplistic hr views
to see that new clinical data has been
reviewed for example
and then bookmarked for user for that
user and documented as reviewed by that
user in the ehr
so that they don't need to go and
manually document that they reviewed
information
but that that metadata for example is
recording it and that that's sufficient
also to implement personalized cds with
ai to drive user specific workflow and
care recommendations
around policy and advocacy um
to urge nih that includes nlm and pcori
hrq and onc to fund research related to
capturing
all coding information without um
coding meeting billing information
without engaging any clinician time
so an approach approaches to doing those
payers to clarify and unify rules
develop data handoff handshakes create
prior authorization call centers and
student responsibility for
code validation related to education and
training to select best of breed and
implement systems throughout the
healthcare system through a mixture of
public and private funding
and then in terms of technical
innovation to develop technology to
reliably
and accurately create reimbursement and
payment data for all
care settings without clinician
engagement using different
um there was a talking using different
av audio visual components and care
settings to capture
all information relevant to coding and
note generation for example
so some key takeaway points from the
symposium at the point where we are
now um you know we brought together
over 300 stakeholders there were
presentations from 33
um individuals that represented a
variety of different professional
organizations
and and expertise um documentation
burden has numerous contributing factors
so
really high level summary of some
findings work to date has untangled
some contributors to burden we've
presented several action-oriented next
steps
we found exemplars from other industries
and clinical settings
and the next steps will involve working
with providers health systems health it
vendors and national policy advocacy
groups
some specifics around that i talked
about how we have all those resources
up on the website um we're
currently doing many national report
outs
you know including seminars such as this
which is great it's great to present
um you know to groups such as you who
really are
include you know a lot of people um on
the ground doing work in this area
we're developing our reports right now
and
creating a network of allies you know
through some of these dissemination
activities and conversations
and then there is a need we recognize
this and
and this is what we're working to try to
promote
is to convene key stakeholders from the
community to mobilize strategies
nationally so really to have
for instance national academy of
medicine cms onc
ama a a begin to have their strong
working groups
that move this initiative forward
um so shifting gears a little bit here
for the last
few minutes i'm going to talk about some
of the research
that i've done and and collaborated with
people on
to begin to quantify and measure burden
and i say begin because i think we
really are
beginning you know i talked about um the
um
the scoping review that a student of
mine did finding
that there really is a lack of standard
ways to measure burden there's
there have been plenty of great papers
but stack of learned
standard ways to measure burden so we're
looking at different
different approaches ourselves um and
and but with the vision and you know
we're not
not quite there but with the vision of
how do these come together in a
framework
that can um really drive this work
forward and
begin to standardize it but i do like to
start with this slide
this is from work several years ago
but it just um it kind of reiterates to
me every time i look at it
like why why we're doing this again
um you know and that when you think
about the problem of documentation bird
you really kind of have to look at it
through a number of different
angles um you know so we talked about
measurement but
let's like take a step back and look at
what's really in our systems
at the same time so um
we looked at the clinical decision
support that was available for nurses
and this was in a vendor-based ehr
um and unfortunately
a lot of the clinical decision support
was
supporting documentation so it was
supporting
oh a reminder to document your plan of
care
a reminder to document this compliance
measure
and this taskless item and you know that
you have missing required documentation
over here and
your patient education documentation has
to be done
you know so when we start to see that
it's probably a symptom
of um you know a poor configuration of
the record for
you know four ways that we do or don't
at all
support workflow and usability and so
if we look at it with the lens of the
data information knowledge
wisdom framework um which you see in the
triangle here
we can say okay this clinical
documentation support that's really at
the bottom right that's just like the
capture of data
but we want our clinical decision
support to be supporting us at this
level of knowledge and wisdom and so
we just need to keep this in mind and
work towards that
and so i think at least once we start to
see no longer a need for
cvs to really you know be
largely focused on this documentation
support maybe
maybe that shows us that um that we've
improved
um but certain certainly we want our cds
to
you know be promoting top of license um
practice for all of our clinicians
so some other work um that we've done
focused on nursing documentation in the
acute and critical care setting
was simply quantifying and visualizing
it
um and you know documentation's kind of
been quantified
a lot of times through time like
through time-based measures as i
mentioned before
here we were actually looking at you
know
entry of how many data points are being
entered so
so just quantifying that which hadn't
yet had yet to be
counted um necessarily and so
we found that on average nurses were
documenting one data point
every pretty much one minute in the icu
and about the same average one data
point
you know every 0.82 to 1.14 minutes
in the acute care setting um those those
averages pretty much equate because in
the icu you have fewer patients but you
document
more information per patient um
but you know we found in you just see a
visualization down here of a snapshot
from one nurse's shift that this
documentation
it wasn't just that it averaged to every
minute but they really were consistently
in the record
all through that shift as you can see is
laid out by these different time stamps
um across across the x-axis there
and so i think it just speaks to the
amount of
of time and quantity
that that we really require um
nurses to be in the record as opposed to
you know more direct patient care
a student of mine also has looked at
um through some time motion studies
this notion of frequent task switching
in the context of documentation burden
so you're in the record you're entering
data then you're viewing data then
you're putting a procedure in and then
you're putting an order in for instance
and how quickly you're switching back
and forth between those activities
and overall you know it it seemed to be
that
clinicians were switching between
activities
every um or had or had about
one one uh one and a half switches
every minute which seems pretty high so
just another
attempt to measure documentation burden
there
um but also from one of our studies
which is called the concern study and
it's funded by the national institute
for nursing research
we look at optional documentation
that is recorded by nurses and we look
at it for the purpose of predictive
modeling we model
patients at high risk of deterioration
in the
icu and acute care setting and we've
been able to use
nursing documentation signals
in in a predictive model that actually
predict
patient deterioration about 40 hours
before
leading other other
leading early warning scores um why
you know because we're using signals
that the nurse is worried about the
patient
as opposed to late signs of
deterioration
which are in most other early warning
scores which are vital signs so the
vital signs don't change until
you know that deterioration is occurring
at that moment
but but it's been shown um
that a nurse's concern is enough
information
to act for a patient and for instance
call a rapid response
so we actually have been able to
quantify that
through looking at nurses optional
documentation
so when they document above and beyond
when there are more vital signs
documented and this looks at the
metadata right so so we're not looking
at the value of the vital sign we're
looking at the sheer
presence of it and the frequency of it
as well as other things
the frequency of nodes um the
frequency prn medications and so there
are a variety of features in our model
and it's not not the point of this slide
you know because talk but we see the
value in looking at this optional
documentation
for documentation burden too
so um
what we see is that optional
documentation is where the signals are
you know and it's the signals of nursing
decision making
and the nursing process and that we
that's where we can really find
valuable information um
for predictive modeling but also to
understand what was done
for the patient because unfortunately
sometimes the required documentation
ends up being very standard and all the
same
there's no variability across different
patients
and you actually do want variability
across different patients in order to
have information right um and
and there's a notion that you know a
standard of care shouldn't actually have
to be
explicitly documented because it should
just be done
we shouldn't have to ask nurses to
record that they did the standard of
care
um so what we've found
is that um you know like i said that
optional documentation has really
important signals and i think that this
is an approach or a lens
in which we can start to look at burden
our team's starting to look at
burden from that perspective but you
know our study really was
coming from the from the standpoint of
predictive modeling
actually you know a different aim and
focus but but we see
the benefit combined there we also then
um this past year then looked
at the documentation
manual documentation entries you know
not things that are automatically coming
from devices
but manual ones per nurse per patient
shift
we plotted them out from year of year
from this past year
and then the past three years before
that
because we knew that when the cove
pandemic hit
at least for our hospitals in the
northeast um
because this includes some multi-site
work you know there were changes
to um to the record for nurses
um the records ehrs were put in their
disaster mode which is essentially
intended to
you know decrease the amount of
documentation that's required so we
wanted to see what happened
to the actual documentation that nurses
record again looking at this from the
lens of
okay all of a sudden nurses aren't
required to document a bunch of
information
so what did they choose to document what
was that
optional documentation they chose to put
in there
interestingly you see that red spike and
that's when we all kind of know
covered first hit right you know so
that's march
into april so documentation increased
um very interesting you know my take on
that
is there were a lot of really acute
patients and clinicians recognized
we need to understand these patients and
you know we don't know that
we need to record this information and
that's a path to starting to understand
those patients better
but then um once the hr disaster modes
were put in place kind of a month or so
later
documentation didn't go below baseline
it actually
just went back to baseline where you
would presumably think it
would go below baseline so again
thinking that this
starts to point to the fact that
nurses increase their documentation when
they see
the clinical need for doing so and i
think this is a good lesson to keep in
mind
um when we think about you know
documentation
burden and the regulations that we put
on nursing and how we should
actually be reflecting on their
professional practice and their autonomy
a bit more
um so you know our team has found the
act of documenting a free text comment
or other optional
data and a flow sheet knows rose
information the nurse likely determined
an event or observation
was clinically significant enough to
record
so we've found in our work that focusing
only on the values of each our data
actually missed these healthcare
processes
that you can look at um you know instead
and this approach can shift how we
understand leverage clinical
observational skills
and clinician-entered data to measure a
variety of things including
burden um
to point out really quickly as part of
this
work we did plot our predictive model
against other early warning scores in
the context
of um of
racial disparities we did find that
there were disparities in other early
warning scores
we actually purposefully
um included features in our model to
mitigate
those racial disparities um and
and so that's why you know there aren't
significant ones in our model
but i just point this out because we're
talking about documentation burden
but there really is clear evidence that
our ehrs the documentation in our ehrs
have bias they have um bias
along racial and ethnic lines as well as
i'm sure others other categories as well
and so again important to reflect on
when we think about documentation burden
and how we may
intervene on it um so to kind of sum up
you know the last few slides you know my
team we look at what we call healthcare
process
modeling identifying features from user
interaction with the clinical systems
which are patterns of
clinician behavior we then um you know
interpret those patterns as proxy of the
individual's decisions knowledge and
expertise
and you can use those patterns and
predictive models for association with
outcomes
importantly including clinical domain
expertise for their interpretations
but again applying this to the concept
of documentation burden
in you know some innovative ways to
think about the problem
so to finally um sum up
some some of some of this work um
you know bringing it together from the
symposium findings too
you know some of the things we found and
especially within the nursing domain
um talked about issues with accrediting
organizations
versus the we've done it to ourselves
and over building these ehrs
there's some lack of clarity and the
rules that are put out there and
different interpretations
this we've done it to ourselves might
come from this gotcha mentality where we
over build our records and have a fear
of
litigation and document a lot in there
to kind of cover
cover your butt and make sure it's in
the record but what are we really
missing because of kind of this cycle of
burden and there are certainly many
other factors
into this cycle of burden you know
usability being one workflow
being another reimbursement being
another but
we're missing in the nursing domain at
least i think there are parallels
um to other healthcare providers but
personalized nurse care planning
opportunities for higher level clinical
decision making
capturing synthesis of the patient's
story and communication of key patient
information to the interdisciplinary
care team
and so with that i am going to end and
hopefully there's some time for
questions
thank you great
thank you um very very interesting
talk i will uh um ask the first question
and actually preface it with a comment
um you know it's amazing to think that
it's
you know it's what about 12 years since
meaningful use when
we went from almost no use of uh
ehrs to now they're being widespread and
and
us in the informatics community kind of
bearing the brunt of people complaining
about them right rightfully so but it it
is um
i i never would have imagined we'd be
talking about these sorts of things
um so but my my question is um
um i i you know i certainly understand
the tagline and
and you've presented a great uh you know
plan for
for clinicians in education and policy
and all that
how will how will you know um
that this especially since we really
can't measure burden precisely because
there's so many measures
how will you know in a few years that
that this initiative has
succeeded what what what kinds of things
would you be able to point to
yeah that's a great question so sir
those are certainly some things that are
are i will emphasize our weekly meetings
with the steering committee are still
struggling with
right i mean you you need to measure in
order to know and we need some
some more and better measurements um i
think that
some of the measurements will will have
to do with
engagement levels and you know movement
in kind of that policy advocacy and and
vendor space so not
just you know measures within our ehr
but measures around different rules and
so forth
and i just highlight that because um
more
recently in the past a month or two
like it was noted that there have been
changes to
some physician you know billing
regulations and
actually they've been great and so some
of it
it was noted that what we're lacking now
is awareness
that that's you know awareness kind of
broadly or you know
um talked about more um at scale if you
will
that that really helped and that those
have been really good and so that's one
side of it but that's kind of more the
softer
softer side um
not necessarily easier but when it comes
to measurement
perhaps a bit easier but you know the
dissemination is like so important and
the engagement
so important but but i think some of
what we say
you know that there needs to be
engagement from national organizations
and working groups around that you know
and engaging organizations like omc
and hl7 and and so forth that
measurement needs to be a part of that
that needs to be early in the
conversation
our symposium didn't did not solve that
problem
and it needs to be front and center in
um in how we're gonna get there great
well i think i see other people turning
on their screens so i'm just gonna
open up to the audience to speak up if
you want to ask a question
hi sarah it's dana so good to see you i
always enjoyed
following your team's work and enjoyed
the presentation
i had a question your concern project
really demonstrates the value
of nursing judgment in what they
document and how that
you know really correlated with with
patient outcomes do you think that
that could possibly be a strategy for
reducing documentation
where we i'm sure there's ethical
considerations but where you almost
removed all documentation requirements
and allowed them to
document what per their clinical
judgment they felt was good
and then some combination of that plus
what other people
review of what they document and the
record could become like a new minimum
uh standard i just wondered about your
thoughts about how we might even go
about doing that type of a study
yeah yeah and i love i love how you
articulated that
i absolutely agree um we were actually
hoping
and and still are and looking at it and
and this is
uh something that we are um starting to
study
is using covet as a natural experiment
to start to look at some of that
um because because yeah how do you act
you know how do you get a hospital to
all of them say okay we'll get rid of
you know all the regulations we have and
you can experiment on that that's a bit
more challenging but we actually have
this opportunity
with all the changes that did occur with
covet to begin to demonstrate
um that the value is in the
optional documentation and i think we'd
have to demonstrate it pretty robustly
from a few different angles
to you know to begin to um make it so
that
um hospitals felt comfortable making
those changes
but i think that there's some positive
from covet that it was recognized we
need to change
our systems and so there's some up there
is some opportunity there
um but um but yeah
yeah i i think absolutely that um
you know kind of turning it on its head
and saying
let's see what the nurses document and
um
and kind of maybe looking for gaps in
quality there as opposed to building
the ehr against you know every quality
measure that we can think of
hi sarah this is ruth schleier i haven't
seen you for a long time
good to see you i i did want to just
comment related to kofi that we
moved to a disaster documentation
standard operating procedure during that
time
and did a survey of our nursing staff
afterward to get a sense of
their experience with that standard and
we asked a question
around whether they thought that having
the standards supported their ability
to document based on their professional
clinical judgment
so you know maybe offline it wasn't a
formal study
but you know it might provide some
insights of qualitative
data that's great so yeah
yeah and and overall did the nurses
prefer
uh it was mixed yeah okay we had some
mixed results
it revealed some cultural things that um
we need to pay attention to
interesting yep interesting uh
my name is deb levy and i'm a student um
and clinician practicing
um and i actually did not do research on
it but i was
interested in reflecting on the um sorry
sore voice today too many talking
through masks and n95s last week but um
the concept of complexity offsetting and
you brought that up in a couple of
sections that when the complexity went
up in covid
that nursing documentation may have
increased kind of along the lines of
your concerned study but with a kind of
covet slant
and i was interested in anecdotally
experiencing that as clinician
and watching our documentation burden
actually go
up trying to explain what we were doing
with the novel condition
and so i i was com both fascinated and
it resonated with my experiences i don't
know what the data is but i just think
that's a
incredibly powerful concept of we were
free to write less but
could you really do it and still capture
what you're
trying to take care of in a novel
condition
yeah that's that's great thank you for
sharing that
i mean it makes me think of
you know what what we always want to say
is right the documentation
should reflect the practice right
and and not not more but not less
you know so in my mind as a former icu
nurse
that makes sense and and it helps the
individual nurse probably
you know our clinician process the
information um
because it is new information to them i
you know i think in terms of figuring
out how to care for those patients
um yeah i think there are a lot of
interesting cognitive studies that could
be done from
around that issue too thank you
hi sarah how are you it's good to see
you
youtube great talk this is fantastic
one thing that i was wondering if you
could speak to a bit more and you did
touch on this
but if or to what extent you
see um kind of the usability of the data
at the point of care factoring
into this sense of burden um
you know i have to imagine and i've
spoken to clinicians who say this that
part of what's so frustrating is
it's not just that they spend the time
documenting but that they feel that the
data are then not really actionable
either they can't get them back out or
they can't get them out when they need
to
yeah yeah absolutely that that came
across very strongly in the symposium i
think
through a few different factors like one
being the notion of information overload
which
you're talking about which we didn't
necessarily talk about a ton
in the symposium but it but it was
brought up
you know your review of the data it
that can be burdensome um it's not all
about data entry
um but but certainly it's burdensome
just to
try to process the information and find
it
um but also it came up in the sense of
um
it just propagated double documentation
because i can't find that information
though i know it's in there
so i need to document it again just to
kind of
cover myself you know or for
completeness in my note and so
it was it's it's a big cycle that occurs
right and that was one of the reasons
that i think there was a strong
discussion too of the need for for
better team-based
documentation you know so so they tie
together
very closely that i don't need to
document
you know um my t the same thing that i
know my team member did whether they're
in the same you know discipline as me or
not
you know we're team members and i should
be able to rely on their documentation
but if i can't find it
and it's not really set up for
team-based documentation and it's not
going to happen
great thank you
great maybe we can um either take one
last question
or otherwise we can
call it a day it's been great to see
this nursing informatics reunion
columbia reunion
activity um well um thank you so much
sarah i
um this is a really fascinating project
i'm sure our field is going to hear
a lot about this going forward um
maybe unfortunately in this in the sense
of where we're
solving a problem that our systems uh
created but
but actually i i do like what you said
about you know these are really early
days i mean
even though ehrs have been around a
while yeah
well good okay well um thank you again
for presenting
and um uh thanks everyone for attending
and
have a great day and those in portland
can go out and enjoy the nice weather
okay take care everyone bye bye